my apologies welcome to the cabinet
today on the 4th of March uh and can I
just say we thank you and Welcome to our
guests here today uh and uh I do hope
you uh enjoy seeing us uh make our
decisions today at the cabinet so moving
on we've got apologies for absence do we
have any apologies for absence I've
received apologies from councelor
OK and do we have any disclosures of
interest um to that anybody wants to
declare on any item that's on the
agenda moving on we have the minutes of
the previous meeting that was held here
um do we have anybody that wants to
raise any questions about the minutes or
are we happy to accept them uh and move
on do we do I have a proposal for to
accept the the minutes um count David
councelor coucher has has proposed do we
have some and councelor Curtis has
seconded are you all happy with that
agree thank you moving on then to the
next item which is um matters to be
referred to the council there were non U
matters for decision by the cabinet and
uh the first item is the performance
monitoring report uh which is to
consider the performance achieved during
quarter 3 April to December 2023
monitoring the delivery of key
performance
indicators uh we've got a a good report
here that has lays out the the 26
performance indicators that were set to
bitor Performance in year three 16
related to council plan objectives and
10 of corporate health
indicators uh and um we've got uh two
indicators that have not been reported
for for good reason one um outside body
unable to supply result and the other
one uh due to a systems upgrade uh the S
the indicator has not been reported uh
but if if I could take any questions
about any of the targets and any of the
key performance uh indicators that are
on in the appendix one have to see what
uh what what information can be gathered
councelor Curtis thank you leader yes I
know the um and I think I've mentioned
this in cabinet Forum I know we haven't
got a report on the heart performance
indicator but I just like to sort of
flag up that various concerns have been
raised over performance of heart over
the last year so I think if we I'd just
like to have that noted please thank you
leader yeah and this was discussed at
the overview and scrutiny committee as
well I understand so um that um that
that has been through that process um
councelor do you want to say anything
about that I don't mind if you want know
or bring it up through the my normal
part of the agenda
so so we have uh
okay
okay councelor rock if councelor Rock
wants to come
in
a
second right I'm own business thank you
very much yeah um I I'll look across to
that side of the table on the um
residual waste per household and the
December big is are provisional I just
wondered if there's an update on that uh
presumably this is something to do with
peculiar period of public behavior that
has some sort of effect on
that
uh yeah it's so it it was a bit of a
strange one that we suddenly had a jump
in um residual household waste we know
not why um but no we we don't get the um
the the confirmed figures until the end
of this month because they're kind of a
quarter behind so as soon as we get them
hopefully they'll be a little bit better
and and hopefully this this T this
quarter will uh will be better again and
it was hopefully just a temporary blip
in people's behavior
thank you for that information and and
explanation have we got any other
questions that want to be raised uh
councelor W hoggins yes I'm I'm sure you
won't mind me raising this but it is to
do with the um average end to end time
for overall disabled facilities grant
case delivery and this is something that
has come before this Council on numerous
occasions in the past and it's the
holding to account of a of a third party
I realize that and it's the really is
the is the progress that's being made in
order to ensure that our residents are
getting a rapid response to their needs
and what your plans are in order to to
to do that I know that um it's not been
reported I assume by heart um but it is
again just some reassurance for our more
vulnerable residents as to as to what
we're we're going to do and and what's
going to be achieved this is not a
reflection on this report it is just the
fact that um this is this this really
does matter to people and that the
response is as rapid as possible thank
you I perfectly understandable because
I've raised that myself in um over the
last two to three years um that there
were problems but uh Anette Homer who is
our head of Department would be able to
say more thank you chair um yes whilst
it's not reported here what I can
confirm is there's being um a total
review of the process of how heart Works
um but also um on a positive Point our
budget and the number of um applications
that have been processed is far ahead of
those of the other districts so we are
pushing those through um so I think the
the service delivery on the ground is
better than it would appear from this
report but we need those figures to be
able to uh you know and that they would
I hope that that will come as soon as
possible thank you very much we have a
recommendation and that is that the
position in relation to quarter 3
Performance monitoring report 2023 24 is
received and any issues identified for
further consideration be addressed by a
further report to the cabinet and the
portfolio holder so those items some of
the questions that have been raised
today will be will come through that uh
recommendation with the with any further
reports uh do we have somebody who will
propose that councelor Kohl's and
somebody a second councelor grott are
you all in in uh Accord with that and do
you agree okay thank you moving on the
next item is the Performance Management
framework proposed key performance
indicators and council plan actions
thisan is a really important uh item
because it considers the proposed
council plan action and key performance
indicators and the monitoring
Arrangements that will go forward for
2024 25 on the new council plan uh it is
essential that we have those um that
that that we have those indicators and
that we're able to monitor uh that we
are doing what we said it in the council
plan so we if if you go through the
document you will see that there's
several I several uh targets that we
need to uh set ourselves and um some of
them are already have already been
achieved um you know despite the council
the council plan being recent recent and
we are for example now publishing all
public meetings on the SDC channel so
every meeting now is is published and
available for the um members MERS of the
public to see uh and we've also um done
the report that is going out into the in
the council plan leflet uh posting uh
which I think is was a really good
leflet and and I hope that will help
people with um learning more about how
the council what the council is doing
but I don't know if there's any
questions on any of the items that we're
going forward um because some of them
are not yet determined as to when
they'll be reported or what format but
they are
uh they are our actions to go forward
and we do need to make sure that we we
do um monitor our performance councelor
Kohls uh it's not a question as much
it's I think it's giving ourselves a
good structure to actually
form projects that we can achieve and
Mark you know essentially Mark ourselves
against the action plan so I think it's
a a good structure to take forward and
work
within thank you h councelor w hoggins
yes I know that a lot of the status is
is TBD which I assume is to be to be
decided to be determined sorry um but
also I know and I raised this previously
that um within the council plan action
that that you've written is that there
is um a distinct lack of the cost for
each item here because one of the key
performance indicators of um actions is
um you know the budget that you've set
aside in order to make that uh happen
and also then um whether or not it runs
over budget or under budget as well
that's something you know for the
transparency for residents that that is
important and I and I'm I'm disappointed
that that is lacking from this plan that
there is there are um you know set aside
that the money that these each of these
items is going to cost for residents
thank you uh I'll bring the chief
executive this time thank thank you
leader um the two points the reference
TBD I should have put a key on that and
apologies it is to be determined we're
setting the the council plan actions
today and we will monitor them it's a
bit early to monitor the some of them
before they've they've actually been
established in relation to the costs for
the delivery of the council plan you
recall at Council last week short
meeting that we had where we set the
budget there was 2.2 million that was
put aside for the council plan and
change program and if there are resource
requirements coming forward to implement
the actions then there will be further
reports to the cabinet about how that
money will be spent what one particular
area that I can say with some certainty
that we'll be looking for some cabinet
support on is around things like the
apprenticeship program that we want to
implement underneath the the staff
strategy which itself is one of the the
junior documents if you like to the
overall council plan so the cabinet will
be the form there'll be full
transparency about how that that
resource will be
deployed yeah y another question yeah
it's it's only to go back to that yes I
I'm cognizant of the 2.2 million that's
set aside for the plan but again it is
which how much of that 2.2 million is
going to be set aside for each bit here
because at the moment it just look looks
as if there's a glorious pot of 2.2
million which we must never forget is
hard-earned taxpayers money that's
that's formed that pot and I do think in
the interest of uh one of your um your
first priority here is to be transparent
be a transparent council is to know
exactly how much of that money is to be
spent on each of these objectives thank
you
that will be part of the the regular
monitoring uh Financial re review that
that comes to every single cabinet uh
and every single item uh will be will be
costed for example we are putting aside
uh an amount of money to for the uh
community Transport Service the the UB
there is a sum of money in here to
support the service but we are waiting
on the county council's procurement uh
before we can make a final uh decision
on that one uh so sometimes it we are
Rel I on other people and being able to
get the get the actual uh prices from
others as well as ourselves to be able
to put the final um final sums on it but
we've been uh the the it is part of the
the regular review of um an regular
report that will come to cabinet and
everything will be costed um councel and
rock thank you chair um sort of
following on from that on on the TB on
page
41 um the council will launch community
climate change fund it says February
2024 on there and it says
TBD probably that's partially achieved
isn't it because I think we've we've
done that haven't we
um uh I'm just wondering if that minute
is correct in that
table and before uh counselor before
Tony PS comes in um he may be able to uh
also fill in another TBD which is about
the um relation to Leisure Center roofs
in the near future there is perhaps you
can uh update us U that there there was
a a bid has gone in for that uh yes very
happy to do that leader um in terms of
the community climate change fund
councelor Rock yes that has been
launched we are at um for expressions of
interest for the F the first batch of
projects for 50,000 allocation that
you've made to that in the first phase
um we're we're appraising those at the
moment in sort of inviting d bits from
so so that's yes could be has further
progress than suggested when this was
published um in terms of the swimming
pool roof fund yes we have made a a
Grant application a bid application to
the swimming pool roof fund and we were
looking to use that to sort of we've
been successful in that and we're
looking to use that to contribute to the
funding of the photo take arrays that
you want to put on the RO of your
leisure centers we're also working with
the um worksh one one of the local solar
Farms you've got a community sort of
energy fund that that we can sort of
draw some funding down for that so
there'll be proposals coming forward to
the cabinet for both of those and G
course so a lot of these things are
under development but they're not
finalized uh C councelor
coucher thank you very much chair I mean
I think one of the areas which is
fundamental to quite a number of these
objectives is clearly the review that
we're doing of our planning service
going forward and clearly that will be a
call on the 2.2 million PS that we have
but at the moment we still don't have
the complete scope of that work yet
outlined um so I think this is this is a
document that's going to develop I think
uh quarter by quarter going going
forward um and at the moment we can't
just allocate sums of money money out
willy-nilly here we need to see some
precise costings about what that's going
to
involve one of the um I'll bring
councelor Curtis in in a minute but one
of the things that I'm particularly uh
pleased about is the fact that uh we are
it says to undertake discussions with
environment agency 7 Trent and War
County Council surrounding drainage and
sewage uh and then promoting good
practice across the district actually
we've already started that as well we've
already had the the some initial
meetings and I have to thank our our
head of service for U the work that was
done during recent flooding events and
the emergency work that was done here at
at straa District Council uh we are um
not the flood Management Group at all uh
that is the County Council but we are as
take our role as being a convenor to be
able to bring together a disperate
partnership to be able to make sure that
uh we are um using those Powers but also
um Translating that into the work that
we do in the local plan as well to to um
adapt to you know to work uh and we have
to work with other partners but it is a
partnership work uh and we have to work
with the lead flood Authority which is
the County Council on that councelor
Curtis thank you chair leader um yes
Communications has already been brought
up this morning in now in our session
earlier on um and I'm pleased to see on
page 33 development under my portfolio
wide ranging digital strategy reviewing
method of communications review of the
council
website these have been in the
Performance Management framework and
been reported as being ongoing for some
time but I would really like to see that
working with the team this will actually
be delivered this time thank thank you
yes indeed and and there's several other
things that we need to you know for
example the funding for the uh rural um
the crime um work rural crime officer
role uh is already through and um was
part of the budget so and I I I had a a
very good meeting with a couple of them
at one at um greaton Parish council's um
Community Day uh on Saturday so I was
really really pleased to see thatp that
team um and anything else and councelor
Crump yes there's a couple of things um
just briefly talking on um at uh have
you in scrutin on Friday again we spoke
about prioritizing direct contact with
residents um that was one of the things
and particularly not one size fit or not
one in terms of um the demograph of our
our population and also the the
obviously the east south Northwest parts
of the the the district as well so um I
think that's important we also spoke
about yeah the need to improve the
website that came from a couple of cers
um that had cross Party Support um
regarding um I totally agree with
Council cacher and Council C is probably
surprised about that because I'm
agreeing with him because we spoke about
the S allocations and I think to review
the process before you spend the money
Etc and obviously see had a big input
and I know ker keithy and I both worked
on that as well uh in in response to
that so I think that is makes sense in
his wise I certainly agree with that um
I think we would like to see where it's
possible and I know these coming forward
on a courtly basis the
progress um they just seem to be a lot
and I know we're all busy and stuff
we've got a lot on it just seem to be
lots going on so again have we got the
capacity to do these things as well um
and will that cause any delays um
particularly when we've been speaking
about staff absences um impacting on
some Service delivery so again that's
balancing that uh that
conundra um you spoke briefly about the
flooding and the drainage and I can't
resist coming in as portfolio holders at
the county I think there's Works does
need to be done um particularly for
coordinating the street sweeping Council
Rock and I have discussed and we'll
probably be discussing it napton tonight
as well um and I think there's there's
some works there can be done so I think
that's quite
important would also be good to see um
obviously some of these some of the
works are started already so if there is
a possibility you obviously I know sorry
Julie close your ears you know obviously
there been some work done on the he V
project so it' be interesting to see
what expenditure was was on that whether
things have
so yeah I think lots of good work here
if they can be broken down into yes this
is likely to take place very shortly
this is what we spent already or this is
going to be funded from uh this fund or
that fund that that would be helpful and
I know councelor Curtis and I have both
agreed again very RAR again but we've
both agreed to do with the climate
change panel where there's lots of TBD
or ongoing or t you know there was no
definitive time scales uh and I think
that is helpful as well because members
of the public will be seeing lots of
good initiatives but not potentially
knowing when they're going to happen so
I think some clarity around those would
would be helpful you know and and again
you're ear in the process so we we are
pragmatic enough to realize that these
things will take time to Dev but it
would be good to see the progress and
and and put out in a simple form that
the chair of overin and he can
understand readily as I'll I'll bring in
uh Council Rock but uh we we've always
as a council done uh a quarter quarterly
performance monitoring report on the
previous council plan we agreed a
council plan at the at the last council
meeting and this is the first action
plan now uh for uh for those performance
monitoring uh indicators going forward
so we will continue with the the same uh
quarter the quarterly performance
monitoring report we actually have a
very very good uh performance monitoring
uh Team councelor Rock uh thank you
completely new subject um uh but also on
page 33 um which is the um local
council's Charter now I recognize this
is working across all of War here um but
it's something the chief executive I've
spoken about over some months really I
just
wonder we haven't really even got a
Target here uh and I know we've got to
pull together a lot of strands but we've
got a three level Authority here and uh
I'm
hearing I need for clarity across not
just this Authority but other adjoining
authorities
of it would be nice if we could get
clarification of roles for district
councils working with parishes and uh at
the County as
well I wonder if the chief executive
could give us some warm feeling that
this is progressing or whether we can
speed the pro progress of that um
because I think we do we are looking for
a document that clarifies those roles
particularly for those of us that have
got a large number of parishes I'll
bring the chief executive in I'm I'm not
sure I can give you a warm feeling Nel
um but but just just just to say you're
right we're working collaboratively on
this we got all the district councils
apart from n Eon and bedworth B our
Council of course Nan don't have any
Parish councils at all working alongside
walk the County Council and then some of
the more High high-profile Clarks from
across the whole of the county on a
working group which is reviewing the
charter the charter does lay out already
the kind of expectations what the local
councils can receive from the the
district councils and the County Council
and return what we expect from the
parish
councils the way the the conversation so
far it will be more of evolution rather
than Revolution um we're hopeful we can
get get to a position where we can take
through Democratic processes and each of
the authorities by about July is is kind
of deadline that we're looking for for
the the approval of that document but we
are one of several players in that in
that
discussion thank you uh unless there's
any other questions um there is a
recommendation and that's the sorry
sorry if if I might just highlight to to
the cabinet as well as the council plan
actions we're agreeing also the
performance measures for next year and
there are four new performance measures
which are being suggested those four new
performance measures mirror what off log
will'll be monitoring our Authority by
and I thought it was useful that we keep
an eye on that well you you as an
executive keep an eye on our performance
in their those four areas as well so
it's not just the council plan actions
it is the new performance no no you you
are quite correct there are um there are
say there the in recycling contamination
rate um and I'll bring councelor r in on
that one number of upheld um complaints
uh and a number of other ones that have
been brought in that are are new to the
to the targets um and the indicators
that we set ourselves uh councilor grop
thank you leer yes it was the new
recycling contamination rate I was going
to query I we've got it proposed down as
uh
5% um for
2425 I was just wondering where that
came from I mean currently I the
Sherborn um murf um their contamination
rate is running at about 20% so I was
just seeing one maybe could be more like
15% rather than 5% but I just wondered
what the background was where that had
come from thank you chairman I can't
respond to that particular point the
recycling contamination rate that's been
cited here isn't just from dry recycl
from all of our recycling streams so of
course we do food waste recycling then
we also do Garden waste recycling as
well Garden waste recycling
contamination rate is much lower and it
is heavier than than the uh the current
um dry
recyclers our current performance on on
on the off log website is 6% for the
year so this is a stretch
Target where I'm in your hands here it's
been proposed at 5% if you wanted a a
vary variation that at that Target then
that's absolutely up to you
I think that has been agreed with
officers that uh that 5% is is that
just I think J J May disagree possibly
think this has come from government as I
understand
it would you like to come in at this
point I think i' I've gone into this in
quite a bit of detail um I think the
concern is I mean Mr bookland is quite
right it does include um green green
waste and food waste of which the
contamination is just about zero because
we don't get any reports back of that um
so so the the figure is fundamentally
actually reflecting our um dry recycling
which to date has been been very very
low I think the concern is with with the
new um Sherborn I'm not saying our
contamination will go up but it could
well be um uh Quantified or accounted
for differently because we're in a
completely different environment as to
how it's being dealt with and how it's
actually being sampled so I don't think
there's any guarantee that we're kind of
if you like comparing apples with apples
on on the previous figure and and that
that's my concern and I'd rather ER on
the side of caution but at the same time
absolutely as uh Mr bookland says you
know we don't want to look as though
we've suddenly got really really bad on
our contamination rates because I'm sure
they won't
be because they the facility is actually
taking in waste from far more than just
this one Council now it's taking in
shared from from across uh a number of
councils well that that's sorry that is
the case except they have assured me
from the 1 of March they will separate
our um recycling out completely at the
minute it is dealt with with warik and
as far as they can they will start to
separate that out so that we get more of
a separate figure although we do still
have some joint rounds that collect from
war and Stratford um so it should only
reflect ourselves it's just that how
they measure and how they simple
contamination does vary um from from
place to place so we might see a
difference but if we do see a difference
we can account for why we've got a
difference and councelor rock do you
want to come in and then move on I think
it's an interesting point and it's it's
a wider Point as well because if if
we're going to have a
Target the implication is we've
got control or at least influence over
those figures now this is influencing
the behavior of our residents isn't it
and we've talked about communication and
this that influence is going to be
through
communication uh and I
have someone E when we introduce a new
Target that we are careful that we have
that influence and control over it you
know it's a quality management principle
isn't it the other point that I I would
draw and it sounds like we wouldn't have
that if we got one figure of 6% to what
extent that that is uh one discrete
value and we won't know what that trend
is I mean was there a lot of fluctuation
what confidence levels have we got uh on
on that variation uh going
forward so I think it sounds like we've
got to consider this as being a bit
provisional now it would be unfortunate
in in view of circumstances we find that
this
is relatively unachievable we've set
ourselves something that we can't it's
not really a smart
Target uh and we had to increase it
would we not be better to set us off
something that we could achieve and if
if it it's working out because we we get
better data going forward we could
reduce it rather than go the other
way uh it's a thought I put forward I
don't know whether we could have a look
at this target uh when we've got a bit
more data in a couple of months time
would that be a sensible thing to do CH
chairman if I could sorry chair if I
could respond on that point look this is
your opportunity to set the target for
the year the current performance rate is
6% what we have been told the suite of
indicators at offl will'll be looking at
they don't give us what level of
performance they expect to see in this
area they they judge us against our our
peers and and and we're performing well
at the moment at 6% hearing what what
Julie was was just discussed in relation
to the new Arrangements of Sherborne
whether you reverted to the current tar
current performance is the fugure target
given those uncertainties that that
could be a strategy but but we would
need I'd like to capture that now within
the performance framework rather than
coming back in the future I'd like to
set what our Target is now if that okay
CH no council Curtis you wanted to come
in on this space there a separate topic
leader so if we want
to no I think we should aim high but
obviously uh if there are any
difficulties please do report back um
but I think we we've always performed
well on recycling I I I would hope that
we could perform to this target that has
been put
forward any any count
CES um just a just a query over the T
proposed Target 2024 by units of bed and
breakfast in temporary
accommodation um I'm going to I'll
mention I'll touch on number one Ean
Place Ean Place briefly in my Capital
budgeting report um but given that the
idea I understand behind the purchase
and use of number one Ean place is to
reduce our allance on B&B
accommodation I wonder if that should be
reflected in the Target uh it's on page
47 second column down second line down
in the target for I would have thought
perhaps it would be
reducing um Anette com thank you um I
would envisage that the work on e place
is finished about September time um then
of course we've got to and and before
then we can commission the provider of
the care and support um and get that
sort of unit into the flow from Fred
winter um or directly um let into to Ean
place um we could reduce the Target but
I think probably it'll be next year when
we set a tougher Target because it'll be
towards the end of the year and we'll be
working towards what that provision
really looks like and what it means on
the
ground thank you I've got um who have I
got now did I councelor rock or
councelor grop councelor grop do you
want to come
in thank you leader yes it was just a
separate one as well um again on page 44
the council will review the approach to
engagement with communities and town
Parish councils coming under headed
environmental Neighborhood Services um I
just wanted to query what what did that
um pertain to um because is this through
we have the um the Outreach the sports
and Leisure Outreach workers that that
is a separate um action under this
framework chief executive J I'm I'm
trying to recall the conversation we had
at management team on this particular
issue I I believe you're right I think
it's it's linked to um the work that
we're doing with the active Community
strategy and Everyone Active on on the
Leisure contract but also recognition of
the restructuring that that's been
undertaken within environment and
neighborhood services at the moment to
give that wider Community response to um
well to to to all of the areas within
the council that that that has been
identified part of the council plan
um is under this this area support
parish councils for the benefit of the
commun to support those kind of
localities as we move forward yeah we we
we'll explore that it'll be part of the
report backs that we get in in future
times so moving forward then we've got
the proposed council plan actions they
were on appendix one and then we had the
key performance indicators and targets
that were on appendix two for 2024 to 25
and the recommendation is that be that
they be approved I'm proposing that
recommendation uh anybody that wants to
Second it uh councelor Kohl's are you
all in favor all right thank you thank
you very much indeed and moving on um
now this one is falls under Council of
rock and Tony perks the deputy chief
executive and it's about nine Timothy's
Bridge Road uh and there's several uh
recommendations there but we need to
hear a little bit more about the
background uh thank you chair um well
will have read the papers this is um a
proposal that um will support uh an
initiative that uh homes England have
taken across several sites um it would
enable us to progress what's been a bit
of a difficult area uh and um I would
point out that um one of the things that
um we've been faced with in the existing
Arrangements is a very low provision uh
in that area of um affordable homes and
this would certainly bring it up to um
well it mentions 20% in here our our
general objective in developments is
35% that that is a minimum I believe um
officers correct me uh we we hope to we
would hope to exceed that um and uh it's
a very complicated uh set of Leasing and
ownership Arrangements in the whole area
uh um around there uh but this will
unlock possibilities of enabling others
to um uh release finance and bring
something forward that we simply welcome
uh we're not
entirely uh masters of our destiny in in
respect of others but I uh if uh the
deputy chief executive would like to
help us with a bit more detail I'm sure
he'll put right anything I've said
that's
incorrect thank you councelor rot no
there was there no factual errors in
what you said that's good good um yeah
what we're seeking here today is as
councelor rock alluded to an in
principle decision um the canal quarter
is one of our key sites in our our core
strategy it's one of our key allocations
and it's um the main housing growth
within sort of Stratford which is one of
our is our major town um the existing
site a large part of the existing site
is owned by Barkley homes who are
looking to dispose of their interests
homes England are making an offer to
them and as part of that they would like
us to sort of buy out a lease on a piece
of land where we already own the free
hold it's it's a technical property
transaction and work in partnership with
them um the the key benefits for us is
we'll see delivery of one of our key
sites and we should also be able to
achieve a significant Improvement in the
affordable housing percentage as Nigel
um alluded the the current consent on
viability GRS is only providing 3%
affordable housing homes England's
minimum requirement is 20% and we will
look to get closer to our to 35% as part
of it bit um the point of it not being
masters of Our Own Destiny is this is
obviously subject the deal with homes
England going through we've had um
feedback from homes England this morning
that that is still looking positive um
and if if that falls into place this
will help deliver that without this um
acquisition of the lease it would be
very difficult for homes Inland to sort
of acquire that land so that's the
decision we're making today as I say
it's an in principal decision we've got
the funding allocated from an near
marked Reserve
it'll obviously be subject to sort of
technical due diligence we have a
provisional valuation report which we've
circulated this morning from our valuers
aison young suggesting this is a
low-risk financial transaction for the
council in that what we're requiring is
worth more than we're paying for it um
and so I think we've got all the the key
points in in place to allow you to make
this decision this morning if you're
comfortable about I have M take any
questions U I'll bring in the chief
executive first and then I'll bring in
councelor ccher thank you leader
reference has been made to the valuation
well it's not a valuation per se it's a
letter that we've received from the
valuers that's on exempt that's on Blue
papers if you wanted to talk about that
we would have to move into exempt
session if cabinet were minded to
support this um transaction we would
require a full valuation before we could
we could progress with the with the
purchase I just want to make that
point councilor C thank you um
this council is very keen to get on and
resolve um many of these sites which at
the moment are are not a great attribute
for the town and uh I have to declare an
old interest that I used to work on on
one of the buildings that remains derel
up on on Timothy Timothy's Bridge Road
and frankly I think for for local people
seeing that site at the moment its
current state is not satisfactory um we
have a a indicative scheme there which
frankly is also not terribly
satisfactory to this particular Council
and and uh frankly the amount of
potential affordable housing in that
scheme is is derisory basically and I'm
amazed it it actually went went through
previously I think we should welcome
homes England's um uh interest in the
site the opportunity we have of actually
producing some development which will be
I think a credit to the town um and I
think if that involves a um modest
investment by this Council we should
support
it yeah just to um outline any to
anybody that doesn't know the the
history the master plan was adopted in
uh July 2018 several planning
permissions have been granted on the
land uh but no building has commenced on
the site uh and um this um this proposal
from homes England actually starts to
unlock um the future of that site and if
we can do anything to help uh I think it
would be welcomed councelor Curtis yes
thank you I'm at cabinet Forum when the
proposed housing affordable housing was
at three or five 3% there was a sharp
intake of breath around the table um so
I think if this can move us towards
getting a much more
realistic uh affordable housing
percentage I think that' be absolutely
welcomed councelor
Crump thank you councel jennid um yeah
the deputy chief exec and I have been in
conversation about this uh this item
um it seems to make sense um but
obviously from our view and scrutiny
committee um I'm sure Mr Perks will be
able to brief uh the committee as and
when uh things start to progress um and
obviously there does seem to be quite a
thorough risk assessment on item 6.1 but
again we will be scrutinized that just
to make sure things are going as as as
promised
so we've got the the decision to make uh
councilor Rock do you want to come in
before we move
on I was wanted to propose a
recommendation
chair coun the chief I'm not counselor
yet um chairman before we get to that
particular point I made reference to the
full valuation report that would be
required before we could progress could
we preface recommendation three to
subject to a full valuation report that
the deputy chief executive in con
with the leader Etc be be incorporated
as part of the recommendations councelor
G that is that part your recomendations
one of my questions on this document but
yes thank you that I'm happy with that
yeah so so subject to that uh Amendment
because we do need need to be sure of of
that valuation um this is um a site that
that has permission uh for um quite
considerable number I think it's up to
500 dwellings so you know we are talking
in quite large numbers here is anybody
Council Sarah W
hins thank you chair just really it's a
it's more of an observation than a
question because this is a highly
complicated site we all know that
because this has been in The Ether for
some years now and there are so many
ways in which this proposal could fall
over as it were not withstanding is the
amount that it will cost this this
Council should anybody who is involved
in the sale of any of the land should
change their mind over sale particulars
and I think it's very important within
um this
document or as an an addition to this
document is to say how we intend to
mitigate potential crises along the way
with with this and again you know I know
that homes England are are um are
interested in this but is there another
H if homes England fall away is is are
another um housing provider that will'll
be wanting to step in it is all of that
really that I'm I'm you know it is so
fundamental and important is just having
you know back stop positions each each
way which I think perhaps we we could
have done within the past but we did
have Co in the middle of all of that as
well so thank you councel g um I I I
agree um and that's why I think the
valuation is really important for us to
have and uh and and then the once the
decision is taken that will be for our
officers to to get the evaluation and to
explore and make sure that uh we we've
got the we've got everything um
absolutely councelor W hoggins sorry I I
know this is a key site for all of the
residents and it is that really and it
and again it goes back to the plan is
how we are going to report back on the
progress or otherwise all the obstacles
that have been met and how you know
we're intending to get to to get over
them because never is anything of this
scale you know just an easy you know
chot down to the finish line and it is
it is it is all of that again and that
transparency that that that we need so
that people can fully understand the
complexities really of of it and it's
how that reporting is is going to be
both for residents and for all
counselors because again it's a chunk of
money that is going to be spent on this
thank you um can I ask the deputy chief
executive to give that Assurance please
um yeah I can give um Assurance the way
that we sort of monitor our housing
delivery which is our key thing is is
regularly reported sort of in through
the council's mechanisms at the moment
so we will continue to sort of
monitoring housing delivery if that
starts to fall short currently we've got
a very strong 10year housing Supply so
we're not under a lot of sort of
pressure from this site but it is a key
allocation it is of importance to us
which is hence while we're trying to
work with hes IGN to bring this forward
um if it helps the the cabinet and those
here today the proposal from homes
England would be to acquire the site um
in conjunction with Barkley homes they
would sort of complete the Demolition
and sort of remediate and sort of
package the site and then pass it on to
individual developers to sort of to
deliver probably 100 units a year off
the site so that's how it's Invision to
come forward um in terms of Financial
Risk to the council we are already own
the free hold of the landmark 3 in
appendix one so we're just acquiring the
leas who will have sort of full title to
that
as part of the homes England deal they
would acquire all of the interests in
the um other packages 1 two four and
five so between us then we would have
complete control of that site freeold
and Lease hold and we'll be in a pos
position to package that and that would
vastly improve our chances of deliveries
so that that's what we're doing at the
moment I'm happy to report back progress
on that to anywhere and anyway Ry and if
you want to go into more detail uh you
do have the blue papers in front of us
but we would have to go into exempt if
if we wanted to um you know ask um a lot
of the p a lot of the detail and the
information that you've asked is
actually on that those blue papers okay
so unless we unless anybody's got
anything that they want to further take
on yes well I'm happy to POS this as
amended by the recommendations from
councelor gon chief executive I'll look
for a second U councelor cter seconding
that um we have three recommendations
before us U that the cabinet agreed to
acquire the head leas hold interest of
N9 Timothy Bridge Road that the
acquisition be fund and that is uh
subject to uh an evaluation uh that the
acquisition be funded from the revenue
fund of capital expenditure earmark
reserve and that the deputy chief
executive in consultant consultation
with the deputy leader of the council
the portfolio hold of resources the head
of resources and the head of Law and
governance are authorized to complete
the negotiations required and to
implement the decision and the
alteration was uh that it would be
subject to eval the the valuation uh so
accepting that amended recommendation
are you in favor all right agreed thank
you very much
indeed now the next item um is um one
that um refers particularly to um
statford upon aen um but it's it's it's
it's key part of what uh the district
council does with uh it the the market
Forum the bid the Town Council it's a
partnership there was a contract for the
Victorian Market was agreed in
2017 rolled over in
2022 uh and the report is outlines uh
some of the problems that that report
that contract uh gives us given that
last year the market operated at full
capacity over the over four days caused
considerable congestion and we've had
considerable um uh advice given to us
from the safety advice group uh about
the numbers that can be accommodated uh
and the the problems that arise because
of the weak con um contract um so maybe
councilor grut you could outline that
and and give us a little bit of a
background as to the problems and in the
um difficulties that we're facing on
this problem this issue yes thank you
leer um as you said since 2017 we've
been had a um Market contract where we
run a number um of regular markets plus
um some additional special markets which
the uh Victorian Christmas Market comes
under and and this is run in um COI with
the Town Council um and um our
contractor is um um LSD and they have
been running these um regular events um
one of the special markets that we do is
the um Christmas Market which has been
running since 2017 in 20 um 22 there was
a variation to agree for it to be a I
quote four day Christmas Market within a
town center Christmas Festival end of
and this is sort of part of the issue
that we have at the moment is the fact
that we have a legacy um contract that's
been running since 201 7 uh 2017 sorry
has been rolled over and there is quite
a lack of clarity to certain points of
it so coming back to the Victoria Market
in 2023 victims of our own success we
had um a very very very large um turnout
um we had people coming in that had been
diverted from another Christmas Market
Lincoln Christmas marketing coaches so
we had uh the Town Center at full
capacity we had um various um as the uh
safety Advisory Group uh mentioned we
had overcrowding especially on the
Saturday we had people 12 deep going
around the market stalls um other things
uh the location the bus stops people in
coaches they're getting let out and just
running across the gyory not ideal um we
had excessive noise from a funfare which
was now being part of it um traffic
movement generally across the um
District was not um particularly good um
practical issues such as the public
toilet provision um certain Food hygiene
issues which had been um mentioned
before um and just a general Mission
Creep from the original um markets that
had been put in place from the um from
2017 the safety Advisory Group um had a
review of this and they brought up quite
a few safety issues so the paper that we
are describing today it is to do with
the
safety the town you know the the
Victorian Christmas Market was very well
attended but as is the nature with these
things you know 50% of people some as as
a Town Council said to me 50% of people
are in great support of it 50% people
are dead against it and another 50%
don't give don't okay either way and it
is the nature of the thing if you've
seen sort of the um soorry know we um
you know this is not just bit of paper
here it's been on the front page of the
herald this we need to make sure that um
of everything we get this right from a a
health and safety point of you because
we do not want to take the risk with
visitors and our residents as well one
of the um so the suggestion has been so
I getting back to the point was that um
a num uh that we apply some mitigation
to this now just to stress this is a um
we are in uh Co with the Town Council so
this is our um decision and it has no
bearing on what the Town Council um
decides amongst themselves we do need to
come together and um then have our
recommendation to the um Market
contractor so uh after the discussions
with the um safety Advisory Group and
officers that are involved with the
markets and obviously my head of service
the
recommendation for mitigation would be
that well there was a number of
recommendations one was that I can't
find the
recommendations 62 62 the bottom oh yes
sorry there you go can't read all right
so the options available to the cabinet
were for number one Council the V
Victorian Market which would obviously
address all the safety issues but we do
have other partners that are involved in
this and it is not a unilateral thing
for us to do leave the format as is okay
running from Thursday to
Sunday amend the the form the other is
amend the format to two consecutive
weekends and this would be with a
revised footprint with less Market
stalls to add to the um the space for
visitors also to not have the um the
funfare or the stage which um have sort
of sprung up over the years um and also
all to the third fourth is to propose an
alternative
option so um our recommendation should
be though focusing very much on the
health and safety because obviously
there are lot of opinions about um the
you know what people think about which
car Parks we use uh what the different
stores should be but those are secondary
issues the primary issue is working out
exactly how many the time and the format
of the Victorian Market should be thank
you thank you um Julie Lewis do you want
to come in and uh give us a bit more
background yeah if I can just clarify on
the options so where it says 2.1 cancel
the vcm C can I just stress at this
point because it says after that um LSD
has agreed in principle to the changes I
need to clarify that LSD have not at
this point agreed in principle to the
changes um that their their favor is
that they want another 4-day Market
Thursday to Sunday that we do not see as
a viable option due to the health and
safety concerns um their their
definition of two weekend markets was
actually 2 3day weekend markets would
actually which would actually extend the
market from 4 days to six days um and
and that's uh well I I'll leave you to
make your own decisions on that one but
that was their preference um so just to
stress in terms of contractual kind of
what what they've actually agreed to at
the minute is is actually none of these
other than running it exactly as it is
as it
stands I mean just to stress the the
difficulty is there is a contract for
four days uh and uh so that that is a
contractual but the the contract has no
boundaries so for example in 2007 there
was 2 207 stalls uh last year there was
320 stalls so uh and there is nothing in
the contract that prevents the the the
the number of stalls increasing or or or
going further um The District Council
plays 60% of the um the the the totally
income for you know for that market uh
for the contract and the Town Council
pays 40% so it is a partnership that has
to go between the two and that's all set
in the contract as well I understand I
think I think I'm correct on that one so
we we have um we have to work with our
uh Partners at the Town Council it all
has to go through the markets Forum Etc
and various things to to make sure
before any any final decision so this is
going to be by this cabinet to find out
what the view is of this cabinet uh and
um they say the the main as I understand
it from and please correct me if I'm
wrong but the um the advice from the
safety advice group is that whatever
plans are made there is a serious risk
of being unable to accommodate further
uplift in the numbers within the foot
current footprint of the of the market
uh and there are serious concerns uh on
safe capacity limits and congestion and
in
inconvenience whatever we do we have to
also work with others on the congestion
uh working with the County Council for
example on the congestion issues because
residents were seriously affected by by
the congestion uh I have spoken to quite
a lot of people I I do know you know uh
various points of view that have been
but we are in this position because we
we do have the the contracts exist um is
there any other comments that um that
councelor Groot I don't know whether um
Nigel rock councelor rock wants to come
in at this point and um the chief
executive oh no
coun councelor Crump at the end
councelor Gart councelor Rock and then
councelor and then councelor Curtis yeah
thank you leader um I just wanted to
also add to the um option 3.2 even if we
do decide today to go with the two
consecutive weekends this is going to be
sorry 2.3 sorry can't um even if we do
um decide the council deci the cabinet
decides to go for the uh 2.3 for two
consecutive weekends um this will be
subject to further um you know overview
by safety Advisory Group moving forward
so there would be and one thing that has
come from this is we will be having more
enhanced um process of going of
reviewing the arrangements if a um
Victorian Market does take place this
year and if we are not satisfied that
these these um arrangements are
satisfactory the safety Advisory Group
could then recommend that we don't
um go forward with this thank you so
just to just to ask that question we we
we would have the option of um canceling
the contract but there would be a cost
to the councils both councils for from
from doing that I would assume maybe
officers can come back at the end and
counselor Rock and councelor Curtis yeah
thank you
chair it is slightly uh in that vein of
clarification uh because again we're not
Masters completely of our destiny here
uh and there's a sort of it's the
opposite of no taxation without
representation we appear to get income
from this but we're not we're not
masters of it so we've got a contract
which if we decided to do something else
uh that not all parties of the contract
were happy with we'd have to obligate
the contract in some way on the other
hand if there's some uh major problem of
a safety um nature I don't think anybody
would be happy with somebody being run
over or major accident uh and we might I
don't know I defer to our U legal team
over here but um I'm I'd be very
concerned about uh our
responsibility you know we do have to
have a risk based U view of this uh in
comparing the risk of abating a contract
in some way versus whatever liability we
might have even indirectly for this so I
don't know whether we could have a
comment that du a due um Point um but
I'm wondering if the recommendation
itself worded might be approved uh
improved uh that by saying that um the
option 2.3 is
approved in that we are recommending
alterating altering the format of the
Victorian Market because we can't alter
it can we we can only recommend it's
altered to those that have the decision
making am I right in saying that we're
all we can do is suggest it should be
changed in the contract uh but if um if
LSD don't want to do it we can only
recommend it that's uh that's my
question can I bring Julie Lewis in this
point and then I'll bring in councelor C
councelor Curtis after that yeah I'll
perhaps answer some of your legal points
as well here to to be clear all three
parties need to agree to what happens
going forward but I stress that if if
LSD or the Town Council say well we want
go with another 4-day Market we if we if
you agree now no that's not acceptable
we don't agree with that it can't happen
what what moves forward needs to happen
completely regardless of what you know
LSD might say yeah we want two three day
markets if we don't approve that it
can't happen equally if the Town Council
say they don't want two two-day markets
we have to find our way around what can
go forward fundamentally what the
crucial issue is what we believe can
actually be done on a safe basis so in
terms of running another one 4 day
market we've already established that we
do not believe that is a viable option
um it's been put on the table that we go
to a one three day Market again we would
struggle to justify that in terms of
health and safety how does that actually
you know alter the the kind of um you
know alter the situation that we're in
so all three parties need to agree it
could be that ourselves and the Town
Council agree let's go with two two-day
markets and then LSD say no we don't
want that in which case again we're in
the situation that you know it it
doesn't happen the fundamental priority
is that we need to run a safe event in
terms of contract
costs we've had a look at the contract
the ideal is that the between us we come
to a sensible and suitable solution um
whereby we mitigate as much as we can of
the health and safety concerns that
would allow an event to go ahead should
that not be the case there are there are
various Clauses in the contract we would
have to go through to it through it
there could be costs that's something we
haven't explored because we're not yet
at that position there are numerous
points in the contract that actually say
if it's not able to go ahead because we
can't provide the space which is
probably the nearest Point we've got at
this minute that then then actually you
know it can't run so there are various
bits in there but we'd be guessing to
know where that might might end and and
and what what what court would rule what
way there may be a cost what I would say
is the cost of that will be
significantly less than should we find
ourselves in court because heaven forbid
we've had a crush injury and people have
been you know injured or worse so we
have looked into the contract but
certainly haven't gone down the line of
what will it cost if because I'd like to
think mutually between the three parties
we could come to a sensible solution but
we haven't gone down that line I have
met with marcier and the legal team and
we have looked at various
options thank you thank you um I'll
bring in councelor Curtis um counselor W
hoggins and councelor coucha um and
councelor Crump and um it is of Interest
interest before I I move on is to look
at the Lincoln City council's report on
why they canceled their Market uh it it
is really really of interest uh that if
anybody has the time to be able to do
that uh because uh you know and that
they they canel it for Crush reion say
health and safety reasons but also but
that had a knock on effect on people
coming to our Market as a result
councelor Curtis first then councelor W
hoggins councelor coucher and then
councelor Crump thank you leader were
the Victorian market to continue I do
agree the format needs to be changed but
after rereading the SAG report and
picking up Council Rock's concerns over
safety I'm I remain concerned about the
safy about the level of risk associated
with the event and I having been at ococ
on Friday and I think councilor Trump's
going to pick this up I know that other
councilors share these
concerns I just just wondering if the
portfolio holder can confirm for the
minutes that officers have assured her
that the risks associated with this
recommendation can be managed adequately
and she would be satisfied with those
assurances councilor grot do you want to
commit that that point before we move on
to others yes of course I mean even as I
mentioned before even if we agreed to
2.3 or a another
um option moving forward we are going to
be subject to a heightened um Health um
health and safety event management is
event management and which involves a a
safety Advisory Group um and traffic
management um Etc so these will be with
extra diligence because of the um the
the issues that have been raised quite
rightly at OS and in the cabinet and
basically if I'm not satisfied this
event is uh is safe as the regulating um
Authority we we can just we can councel
it that's what to say Can W hoggins is
next and then councelor coair and
councelor crom yes I'm just placing on
records today at this meeting clearly
it's your decision to make uh but just a
couple of points if I may that as a
regulator Authority if anything goes
wrong this goes direct to the health and
safety executive the reputational damage
should anything go wrong is immense for
this great uh town of ours of which all
residents and those of us working here
are justifiably proud and I would also
urge you with regards to reputational
damage that you know we are living in
living memory we have the hillsbor
crushing disaster and also the badford
fire disaster as well and when you you
talk about those occasions that is what
defines those areas and those towns it
is not anything else that goes on there
that is always always mentioned so I do
hope that in your deliberations there
cannot be guarantees regarding crushing
I think um I think we were very lucky
last year with regards to the amount of
people coming into the town that there
wasn't something that happened and I do
urge you to think of the reputational
damage and also the fact that there are
many parents uh sitting around this
table um and family people and just all
of us as individuals have a right and a
duty to protect those visiting Stratford
on Aven and that is what needs to be at
the Forefront of any decisions that are
made here today and guarantees are empty
when we've got firsthand experience of
just how very bad it was last year thank
you councelor
Crump
councelor couch sorry councelor coucher
came first on the list and then
councelor Crump my apologies I've got at
the list in front of
me thank you um and I think we have to
remind ourselves that we inher inherited
this contract it's a contract which is
frankly not fit for purpose and we have
now got to make the best that we
possibly can of a very poor inheritance
that we we've we've taken on um I think
one of the major issues that we have to
address going forward is frankly the the
the road chaos that was in and around
Stratford on that particular time and
particularly during the weekday when
people couldn't get to work people
couldn't get to appointments people
couldn't get to the hospital it really
was frankly totally an utterly
unacceptable and so therefore I think
moving it purely to weekends I think
does have some some Merit however
clearly the market is out of scale with
what we can provide at and and clearly
there needs to be a lot more work done
in terms of the mintii of that of how we
actually deploy um potential uh stalls
the number of them um and indeed how how
they array I think certainly removing
some of the entertainment um attractions
I think is is a is a is a positive step
I would say in relation to car parking
if it was done at the weekends we need
to be talking to some of our key
Employers in around the town about can
we utilize the nfu car park can we uh
utilize um other car parks that we've
got to try and keep traffic out of the
town and stop um the the chaos we need
to make sure that there is um that there
is continuity and and accessibility at
all times through the town because not
only is the problem about the crush
within the market I'm more concerned if
a fire engine can't get out from Mason's
Road uh with our reduced Fire cover that
we're going to have um have have in this
area then that would be a very serious
matter for us as well so so there are
major implications really for this uh we
do need to make sure the detail is
correct councelor
Crump I was be quite kind to councelor
cach saying you m stuck in for me
because we're similar age and similar
looking but after that comment about the
Fire cover I I I'll probably withdraw
that because I don't think that was
probably necessary and it's not true at
the moment because the consultation
hasn't ended and proposals aren't in
place the the far cover during the day
would still be the same or very similar
because of the availability onc far vs
during the day and this undermines the
fact that we are trying to get people uh
the congestion in the areas I will go
back to the OS I just I'm just not happy
we're not discussing the fire service
consultation he but he did bring the
fact he mentioned the fire service and
it's is part of the consultation and I
don't think it was right for this but we
we'll move on let's talk about T and
Christmas Market concerning the actual
over and scrutiny committee there's
quite a few here and obviously um Julie
and and the rhw and councelor um Curtis
was there as
long we felt that we couldn't give a
specific recommendation to the cabinet
uh from the proposals and options uh
paragraph two um but members did give a
strong steere that the safety of
residents visitors and businesses
should be prioritized over the
commercial benefit to the town so we
needed to make sure that there was the
the specific and significant R sorry the
voice is not really good at um
identified in the relevant risk
assessments have been identified and
acted if we were to go ahead the risk
assessments would have to be robust and
dynamic uh responding to things that
happened on the day um in terms of
congestions and and it was felt that
other councils have canceled similar
markets and I you mentioned linoln as
they felt some of the problems were too
difficult to overcome and whilst um SDC
is getting extra Fu for because of this
there is potential for one significant
risk to health and safety like I said
residents visitors and businesses and
also significant financial and
reputational damage to
stdc so we're also
we also recognize the fact that the town
is currently starting to suffer from
Road works and congestion already so
whether those Works will be done by then
I I don't know I can't remember the time
SC but that might add to it coming into
into town from May 439 is not too bad
but getting out is a
nightmare um so what we felt that um
it's a very difficult one but um safety
of the residents
businesses and people visiting the
market should be given the top priority
um and then um members made other
suggestions such as um parking Etc um
emphasizing how the park and ride might
be
strengthened um and things like that um
but because of the contract when it
first came out nobody onless i' got
Mystic Meg um abilities weren't able to
forecast the the success it had last
year um and obviously the officers have
had a lot to deal with um and I I do
feel so sorry for Julie and Craig and
the team um but we are where we are now
and um no
action is is is not an option um the
2.2 option uh was F not an option from
from osc um other members had various
different opinions so we didn't come to
a consensus but we feel you've got you
need to spend a lot of time and effort
getting this ride if you do decide to go
ahead with this thank you um in the
report it is quite clear um the contract
was extended in
2022 it was extended for five years with
the words 4day Christmas Market within a
town center Christmas f Festival
included in the
contract with no limit on the number of
stalls allow nor any specification of
the footprint and yet the doc the
documents show that we all knew already
that the numbers were rising in
2021 the numbers were
17,45 that had risen from
13,065 into
2018 again um rising up and in 2022 we
already knew that the Figures were
Rising but we did did AG agreed to that
extension of that contract last year the
Figures were up to
18,893 again we do have to consider but
we are constrained by by the contract as
well it it is noticeable that other
other areas like for example although
they're smaller but other areas when
they do Christmas markets do pay a lot
more attention to things like park and
ride for example Le you know in I know
the Ala food festival there's a very
small event compared to this one but all
bus uh buses uh are laid on to be able
to bring people into the town uh through
a kind of a red park and ride system um
and uh and and people are not encouraged
so we do you know that that has not been
put put into place a proper um a proper
uh traffic management plan although is
there it's not obviously is not
sufficient so we've got us we've got a
difficult position the we do have to
work with others on this one the Town
Council as well the district council
before we can alter the format we do
have to look at the contract and we have
to negotiate with the contractors so any
recommendation that comes to from today
is for from our side subject to working
with those other partners the options
available are that we uh we are
proposing that it be over two
consecutive weekends another option
could be that it's canceled all together
but that is for others to decide given
the the that the thing we cannot go uh
given the the um the the advice that
we've been given on safety given the the
the number the obvious and increase in
numbers we cannot uh go to uh either a
three-day or a six- day or or or a
larger market we have to go we have to
look can Julie leis do you want to come
in at this point is it a technical
matter uh yeah I just just wanted to
clarify ify something when you said
about working
with with the with the park and ride we
already do that just I I just want to
bring to your attention the fact that
the fundamental big issue of the health
and safety concern is the amount of
people actually around the market now
the traffic congestion is a problem and
it's
inconvenient it was serious when coaches
were dropping off people in the middle
of the gyory and people were walking
across the road but if we take measures
to actually make it easier for people to
get here and to bus in more buses and to
make more Park and rides and more
parking available I actually have the
concern that we actually make our
problem even worse because we make it
easier for people to actually get here
and our big big issue is the fact that
we cannot control the number of people
that are actually in the area of the
markets at any one time and that is the
fundamental problem so yeah rest assured
we do work with traffic management with
County with parking Etc but the easier
we make it for people to get here could
actually make the situation worse not
better thank you and you're quite
correct and and that's something
councelor cassingham did you want to
come in at this no you don't didn't and
counc do you have a new point at all
because you have already spoken three
times on this I haven't spoken three
times on sorry tce on this actually uh
can I just say that um in
2022 in fact the par the par parking
figures went down by
11% so in 2021 the car parking figures
for the Christmas Market was at
17,45 it then went down by 11% to
15582 so there is nothing in those
figures as it going down and just on
page 61 there is nothing within those
figures that would indicate that there's
then going to be a rise of over over
21% um in in in in attendees and I'd
also like to take take some account of
the fact that to to declare a contract
as not fit for purpose in front of
officers who have written those uh
contracts I don't think is uh is fair or
gracious enough of of this Council thank
you I'm afraid that that is a point that
has been made by by our own officers to
be honest as well so um I I think we
need to kind of unless you've got any
particularly new issues that been
forward I think we may really must move
to the recommendation on this one have
you got anything absolutely new on this
thank you yes I mean I would like
although in in the the 1.1 it does say
that it doesn't specify the footprint of
the Victorian Christmas Market one of
the options I would like to have seen
would be to explore the option of using
the
bankr I I think there is a problem there
because of the the mud and the fact that
it's grass and it people would be
slipping on the mud and we'd have
thousands of pounds worth of damage uh
that we would have to pay for if it's on
hard roads then uh at least we do not
have to pay that recover that damage
councelor G just wanted to clarify if we
were to go for option 2.3 the two
consecutive weekends if there are any
concerns that come up between now and
then can it be stopped because I'm
really worried about
this yes as I mentioned before yes to
say we do have the um retain the
regulatory um responsibility as well but
say I would hesitate to cancel it and on
advice from the the safety Advisory
Group and my officers uh officers who
didn't actually write the um the
contract yeah thank you very much indeed
and um I think we've had a very thorough
discussion of a very difficult subject
uh so we have an A a recommendation for
us this is all subject to that our being
able to now go forward and talk with the
Town Council and the uh and the
promoters uh so the the recommendation
is that this cabinet uh approves
altering the format of the Victorian
Christmas Market to two consecutive
weekends rather than a continuous 4- day
Thursdays a Sunday event subject to the
agreement of statford Upon A Town
Council and obviously there would have
to be then negotiations with the uh with
the promoters as well but it is the two
councils that make those decisions and
we have to take that forward so the
recommendation councelor sorry Julie
Lewis sorry can I just clarify that a
weekend my definition of a weekend is
Saturday and SU
it is two two days it is not two three
days and there has been some confusion
over that oh that that's my
understanding it is a Saturday and a
Sunday the two so the two two weekends
are would make the four days in all
we're going to go to the vote can I have
a somebody that will propose that change
uh councilor grut is going to propose it
uh councelor Kohl's will second it uh do
you agree with that recommendation and
it will all come back to us at a later
stage thank you very much indeed do you
approve age agree thank you I found that
a very satisfactory debate of a very
difficult subject and I do appreciate
your time and your patience uh with that
um we it is a very serious subject so
I'm glad we gave it the time uh that it
deserved moving on we've got the uh
warshire safeguarding annual report uh
and this is councelor co would you like
to outline and give us the background uh
yes thank you leader um this report is
the annual update for noting um by the
cabinet together with a recognition I
think of the success of the warshire
collaboration and the continue
Improvement of safeguarding
practices um the intention is to assure
members that we have a well-developed
approach and that we can have confidence
in
it the council is a member of The Wider
Warra safeguarding partnership and we
work with other public bodies voluntary
and Community sect sectors um we are
committed to the partnership and we
continue with them to develop the
approach
um to ensure we manage the delivery of
the safeguarding responsibilities in a
robust way um the report has a great
deal of data to convey the scale of the
work underway together with the annual
safeguarding report for
2223 the recommendations today are that
the importance of the safeguarding
agenda is noted and a commitment to
remaining a part participant in the
activity of the warshire safeguarding be
affirmed reaffirmed and that the recent
steps to develop improved safeguarding
practices and staff understanding are
noted thank
you uh does anybody have any questions
on on this one um can I emphasize that
this is one area where we do have multi-
agency working uh where we work across a
whole range of Partnerships uh and um
we've not only mentioned the war County
Council but the and the clinical
commissioning groups integrated care
board and the police uh it it is it is
you it is um absolutely ideal that we do
continue in those kind of um that um
agenda and that kind of partnership um
does anybody have any particular
questions uh that they want to raise or
are you happy that we go to the
recommendations which is uh recognizing
the importance of the safeguarding
agenda and the commitment to remain a
participant in the activity of War your
safeguarding that we reaffirm that uh
that we are part of that and that um we
note the uh the improved safeguarding
practices and staff understanding of
those practices it's absolutely key that
um we improve and make sure that um that
we Safeguard all our vulnerable
residents uh adults or children as we as
we go forward um anybody want does
anybody you know have anything that they
want to add that to
that okay so we've got
the the the um recommendations I will
move those recommendations councelor Co
will you second them okay and um how do
you agree to it okay agree thank you
very much indeed that's I I do hope that
we will get um get a a report back of
the of that as it moves forward because
again and a very very important area um
that we're part of partnership that
we're part of the next one is the
approval of the uh procurement
permission to Tender for the community
Builder project uh this was uh one that
applies to statford upon aen to a
particular part of statford upon aen
which are priority WS to have a
community Builder provision and
councilor calls this is your portfolio
would you like to
outline yes thank you
leader
we have um the report within here of the
success of the community Builder role um
within two Wards within Stratford on aen
and we are coming here the
recommendations today to seek permission
to repure the role for a contract term
of up up to five years uh and this would
be two years plus a further three years
which would obviously be uh subject to
Future funding and positive
evaluation the report also seeks
approval for the existing contract to be
extended for a further 2 months to the
7th of August to allow time for a robust
procurement process and then a SE
seamless Service
delivery um the role is jointly funded
with contributions from town trust and
Town Council and as well as ourselves
and it does contribute to several
aspects of the growing opportunities
plan recently approved by the council
and it also addresses the government's
leveling up agenda um your you'll note
under
1.3.1 that funding was yet to be
confirmed um and I can can confirm that
the town trust have committed 23,000 per
anom for 2425 and
2526 and the Town Council have confirmed
£5,000 for the financial year
2425 um I've been on the receiving end
of reports from various organizations
from the community Builder um is a a
great success uh to date um there is an
evaluation included as part in appendex
one as part of our
report learning from the project will be
incorporated into the tender document
and into the pure curement
exercise um and the council's
contribution represents 50% of the total
cost and it is a cost effective and
actually quite Innovative way to deliver
to support to some of our more
challenged communities and uh as
portfolio holder um I have to say that
it is definitely a model that we would
like to encourage um and look at in
future to support our commitments in
other areas as
well um so yes I'd like to REM uh uh
bring forward the recommendations that
uh one permission is granted to repure
the provision um to enhanced delivery uh
for development work in the challenging
challenged communities within the
priority w of Stratford upon aent toown
um that the existing contract is
extended by two months to the 7th of
August so that we can do a good
reprocurement exercise within the time
frame that allows the transition between
the pilot and the repr procured
contract and that the contract award be
delegated to the head of housing
revenues and customer services in
consultation with the portfolio holder
thank you
leader thank you um I I I read this with
interest because um I'm involved in
things in in oler Town Council where
ster Town Council does something very
similar um that um that you working with
their particular um communities as well
I was interested to you know to note
that orbit had withdrawn from from this
one because I've been trying to get them
to be involved in the olster type work
so I'm just wondering whether they had
whether anybody knows of any particular
reasons why they were um why they
decided not to
continue uh yes leader the analysis they
did in terms of those that attend the
events um they decided that there were
insufficient of their
tenants um to Warrant their future
contribution and that was the reason
they withdrew we will continue to
monitor that they're going forward um
and they have said that they remain open
to communication so anything
change thank you and and perhaps where
towns uh other towns are doing uh acttiv
similar activities we could perhaps
again exchange information and learn
from each other um they say I'm involved
in oler Town Council and then there are
will be other towns and parishes that
are doing very similar work but it's um
we can always learn from each other
councelor Rock uh thank you chair in
fact I was going to say something
similar that we have it would seem a
successful scheme here and there's an
opportunity
perhaps to to learn from this going
forward here but we've we've selected
some communities on the basis of super
output areas from what I can see the
problem with super output areas is that
sometimes disguises pockets of
deprivation with it within those uh and
uh one wonders when we've done this
exactly as the leader was saying whether
there's learning points for other areas
some of which might be rural some of
which might
be semi-urban in in Market
towns uh whether we might extend that in
in coming periods uh those learning
points because as I say super output
areas can be quite misleading about
where deprivation might be and uh and
the idea of community building is is
important and many parishes do undertake
that in different sort of ways and we
and uh we were talking earlier on about
supporting those parishes and doing
those Endeavors and perhaps in a
different sort of way so I think it's
very interesting thank you yeah just
being able to learn from it it would be
would be useful for all parishes towns
Etc once once we've got us a successful
um procurement but this is for the
approval of procurement uh permission to
Tender for um going forward councelor
passingham would you like to add
something yeah I I think yeah this is
sound and seems a very uh successful uh
scheme and it's great that um the
communities in deprived areas should be
helped especially at these times um but
there are as Council Rock Says lots of
pockets of deprived uh housing in all in
the rural areas and there's quite a
large pocket in shipston so it would be
nice if similar funds could be found at
some time hopefully uh When there's less
austerity to to fund uh Community
Builders in in the rural areas but I
think there's
also uh a problem with all the new
housing Estates as well which have got
no Community organizations no community
centers no Community Spirits yet so it
would be really useful to have Community
Builder type uh workers in in the new
housing Estates and I know in shipston
but um and then we're going to have it
seems a lot more housing uh s dumped on
us I was going to say that's probably
not the
most uh diplomatic word to but but with
very little infrastructure and very
little support for all this new housing
so it's important that that similar
things like this happen I think yeah
counselor
calls um
yes anyone who knows me is I'm not
backward of of being forward about
proposing spending money on really good
projects like this I think one of the
most invaluable things of this um role
which is interesting that it is a
community Builder and that is what we
are looking to do you have a big area of
Housing and you you don't get time to
build um organically in the way that a
community would over decades so you need
to support that and I think certainly in
terms this has been aimed in the uh
stford Pon aen Town Wards it has been
aimed at areas of deprivation um and
obviously we all know it's difficult got
and getting harder for people and has
had a really positive effect um and I
think that is certainly I think we would
all want to see replicated elsewhere we
will certainly be keeping an eye on it
um taking the learning working with
other groups and hopefully yes to
certainly develop it as a project across
the district thank you I know that when
I went to to see longm and the meon Vil
area uh what was one of my visits um
that was a point that was made then
there about a new community and the need
for helping to form communities uh as
people moved into an area of new housing
of garden village for example so uh that
that was
a John Kord would like to say something
at this point uh thank you leader um yes
and I think the the real benefits um so
we're preparing the South Ro local plan
the real benefit of having a plan is it
puts you in a much stronger positive
proactive position lots of peas there um
to to capture if you like those not just
the harder physical infrastructure but
the softer infrastructure as well we've
we've got an example in the district
where we have had a a commity um sort
Builder type role and it's it's working
really well um so I I think yeah there's
lessons we can learn uh and I think
moving forward we can really roll those
things out to make sure that when we do
uh you know build the homes that we need
across the district we're doing it from
Place perspective and a community's
perspective and not just a numbers
perspective so yeah we we're certainly
just give you members the Comfort that's
certainly the direction we we're
certainly looking to do uh through the
through the new plan and if we can be
proactive about that and positive about
that then uh we we should see the
success I've got two people um councelor
Curtis and councelor Groot no councelor
Groot um councelor gr want thank you
leader um yes I just wanted to commend
the um activities of Community Builders
I've been uh with the Community Kitchen
I've taken part in that also rubbish
friends um it's done lovely it's
wonderful work um the only thing I'd
like to add is obviously um with my ward
it's a lot of new buildings not a
community center but you get a lot of
young families coming in and it's um an
area my um is an area with a lot of a
younger population an awful lot of these
activities so far have been based at the
old Community which is lovely uh just
wondering if there's going to be any
actions going forward more for young
families and for young people so they
don't entertain themselves on the
streets thank you uh thank you very much
I know we the uh debate has gone wider
than the the actual um uh the the actual
recommendations which is uh to approve
procurement but it it does outline how
important we feel this this is that U we
do do work to community to build
communities um so the recommendation is
that per permission is granted to
procure a community Builder provision to
enhance the delivery of Community
Development work in the most challenged
communities within priority Wards in
statford upon aen town that the existing
contract is extended by a further two
months to 7th of August 24 to ensure
that we repr procure within a time frame
that permits a seamless transition
between pilot and repr procured contract
and for the contract award to be
delegated to the head of housing
revenues and customers of his services
in consultation with the portfolio
holder so ladies you have your task cut
out thank you very much indeed uh now I
will I'm happy councelor Co are you
happy to propose it um and councelor
Groot is secondly do you all approve of
it all right thank you thank you very
much indeed that's
again another um good uh
outcome and moving on and this is within
the councelor Curtis's portfol folio and
this is about a payment services
software contract councelor Curtis over
to you thank you leader fascinating
stuff I know um
so this report seeks authority to
negotiate and award a new five-year
contract for the provision of payment
services software which meets the
accreditation standard required by the
payment card industry security standards
Council it's a brief report it outlines
the background evidence based in legal
implications and I've had several
meetings with Mr B section 151 officer
about this and looking particularly at
points
31 um the supplier has indicated that
they will cease to support on- premises
Solutions Beyond 30th of June 2024 and
any security accreditation will cease at
that point and also the legal
implications
511 the terms of the current contract
are not suitable for a cloud-based
solution in fact they're quite out dated
to adapt it to a hosted solution the
current contract would require
substantial modification if not a
complete
rewrite so having had number of meetings
with Mr barl about this taking those
points there I would agree with his
recommendation that the new contract is
negotiated in accordance with option
five paragraph
215 um there is a confidential appendix
which sets out a likely breakdown of the
costs
I was slightly surprised cinet will see
that the figures are based on 8% annual
inflation um given the there is a
government Target of 2.5% from
2025 this may appear on the high side
but it's probably better to air on the
side of caution um but if cabinet wish
uh I'll be happy to take this up with Mr
Burl on his return from a well-earned
break thank you leader and again uh this
is subject to uh an exempt appendix uh
so which um cabinet members uh and
others have um so unless we want to go
into those uh and we don't we would have
to if we wanted to go into those we
would have to go into exempt uh are you
happy that we just continue with the the
debate have you got a sufficient
information um now that you've read the
read those blue papers uh so we have uh
it's again it's a new new contract it
has to be negotiated and it's to be um
negotiated in accordance with option
five which is paragraph
2.5 and um that is to proceed with the
negotiations with the current current
supplier uh etc etc councelor Gest I
just want I wanted if uh counc Curtis
could clarify at uh 2.5 said the
supplier has indicated that extended
temporary support will be provided so
the might should the migration not be
fully complete by 30th of June
2024 I presume the there going to be
something a bit more formal if it all
goes per shape they won't abandon
us thank you very much can I will take
that up with um Mr barl on his return
but thank you I'll make that point with
him thank
you and this is a uh a proposal that is
being negotiated uh but on being
satisfied with the outcome of the
negotiation the head of resources and
section 151 officer it's what the
recommendation is that they be
authorized to award a 5year contract for
the supply and support of payment
services software after they've
negotiated and are satisfied with that
outcome are you happy are you happy to
propose that yes I would like to propose
those two recommendations thank you
leader and anybody wanting to Second it
councilor guest and uh are you happy
that that that those negotiations start
uh with the for the new contract thank
you agree agree okay okay
agreed
moving on and again it's councilor
Curtis it's the capital budget
monitoring period 1 uh to 10 23 to 24
and um would you like to outline what is
involved in this paper and the
recommendations and and the reasoning
for the recommendation thank you thank
you D yes um this report provides the
cabinet with details of the capital Bud
budget monitoring for the period one10
up to 31st of January I'd like to thank
Nicola Reynolds for preparing the report
in dependency
cabinet will see there's very little
change um in the report from the report
presented in November uh in November
that gave the actual and committed
expenditure for the period to 30th of
November was
6,435 th000 as against a period of
6,578 1869 for period 1 to 10 so very
very little change there uh breakdown of
the summary in table one the capital
budget summary and table two capital
expenditure is found in appendix one on
page one and that gives further detail
of expenditure by service on the
following
Pages an appendix 2 gives a summary of
section 106 funding currently held by
District Council um just as a a little
footnote cabinet may be pleased to note
that on the 14th of February the housing
investment panel awarded warshire Rural
Housing Association a grant of $351,000
P from section 106 commuted sums and
that was for a local housing need local
needs housing scheme in broom which I'm
sure we would all welcome um I touched
on eam Place earlier on um Tony perks
has reassured me that planning is
underway and it has further reassured us
it will be good when that does come on
scheme because the annual savings from
Ben breakfast will be in the region of 5
to 115,000 depending on how number one
is formatted and I think just as
importantly as the savings over the mtfs
and and longer term to the council that
accommodation will provide more secure
and supportive accommodation than from
B&B which isn't particularly
satisfactory either for our most some of
our most vulnerable residents uh nor
from some of the neighboring uh
Residential Properties
so um as I said there's very little
change from the previous report uh from
November it comes with recommendations
that the position on capital expenditure
and income for the period 110 of 2324 is
received thank you leader thank you I I
was particularly interested in the table
two and looking at the some of the
recommendations there uh Ean play is
still on you know proceeding and uh um
the gayon light on Heath new community
Hub I think Council Ro will be pleased
with uh and then there's also affordable
housing for refugees as well which is
something again that um has been ongoing
for quite some time so thank you very
much indeed Council huggings you wanted
to come in as opposition leader yes just
to say that um how lucky you are really
that um there was so so much Reserve
held that you've now got a variance a
favorable variance of 2.3 million pounds
which is on Interest really acred from
reserves held um and this is um helping
to offset the vast number of unfa
unfavorable variances within this
report thank
you I didn't really get that but anyway
thank you very much indeed for the for
for um trying to clarify to us what the
the situation is coun I think perhaps
councelor W hoggins is referring to the
unfavorable variances in the revenue
report rather than the capital report
which I just presented okay thank you
that's a bit clearer thank you um moving
on we've got now got the recommendation
and the recommendation is that the
position on capital expenditure and
income uh for the for this period 1 to
10 23 24 received any issues identified
for further consideration to be
addressed by a further report to the
cabinet and the portfolio holder uh
councelor Curtis are you um are you
moving that yes I would like to move
those recommendations and anybody
seconding that I'm happy to second that
are you all in favor of that report
thank you very much indeed
and moving on next one is the revenue
budget monitoring uh and again it's
councelor Curtis who will cover this
item thank you very much C Curtis um
before I present this report what I I
would just like now that we uh the
budget was approved at Council last week
if I may leader I'd just like to thank
Mr Burl our section1 officer and all of
his team for the really hard work they
put into helping us present the budget
and and also the work they put in with
helping the two opposition budgets so I
think that the finance team deserve our
our great
thanks um so moving on the this summary
uh to update the cabinet on the position
of the council's revenue expenditure and
income as at period 10 with an estimated
outter position for each service for 23
24 section two gives the estimate
estimate outter position for the year
and section three the period 10
positions by service section four gives
the estimated outter position for 2324
by service and further detail for that
is given in appendix one and appendix
two gives a breakdown of expenditure by
category section and the updated
earmarks reserves are found in appendix
4 um jessal has provided a helpful
commentary on this and I'll just um make
a few other comments the period 10
position is a favorable
3,146
784 and the estimated outturn for the
council at the end of the year to be a
favorable position of
1,651 th000 this is an improvement of
just over half a million from the
previous report I think Following last
week's budget debate this should give
further Assurance to Residents that
Council finances under this
Administration are being managed
prudently um just a couple of other
small points I'm happy to take questions
I say um
[Music]
312 um business rates this is due to uh
rate liability which was being incurred
by um the uh RSC at 100 100 Mason's Road
um they they did have the lease on that
that has now stopped so we are incurring
that um
liability um
313 council tax the unfair
unfavorable variance there is due to
temporary employee costs um the team had
to take on agency staff as though had
struggled to recruit staff for that but
we've now managed to recruit three
council tax and three benefit staff who
are still being trained and we hope to
use the to end the use of agency staff
by the year end there's also been
significant increase as we know from the
house building um across the district in
council tax properties which has also
resulted in more
work um the hugs the homes upgrade Grant
screen Grant of
246,000 has been received earmarked to
update Heating in properties that are
privately owned criteria have to be met
by applicants um but again this grant
demonstrates this administration's
commitment to supporting some of our
most vulnerable
residents um 315 I've touched on
previously the unfavorable variance
there utility cost rating valuation we
are still appealing that rating
valuation um the new tency Arrangements
entered into by the previous
administration haven't yet been
finalized as we know the expected tenant
didn't receive their expected financial
support from warshire County Council
which is meant to delay um income from
letting the second floor was budgeted at
37,000 for 2526
and 74,000 for
2627 so it's not a major Financial
impact over the term but my
understanding is that the potential
tenant is still looking at alternative
funding and capital is set aside for
conversion costs and refiguring the
entrance Mr Perks is nodding so I assume
I'm right on that thank you Mr Perks um
the corporate budget as was touched on
just now the investment interest shows a
fa favorable variance of 2, 326,000
against the last report of just over 2
million and obviously as we know this is
a result of high interest
rates as previously Mr Burl cautions
against projecting this increased income
forward given the volatility of interest
rates and the international situation
but the year outturn position is
estimated to be around 2,800,000
um going on to the estimated outturn
position this continues to improve in
November the report was a figure of an
estimated outturn of 9 a half million by
January this had gone up to just under
11 million and now the estimated outturn
has increased again to 11,000 sorry 11,
300,000 um and again I think this shows
our success in managing the council's
finances responsibil
responsibility the earmarked Reserves
there has been a slight fall in the
earmarked reserves around
150,000 but earmarked reserves are there
to be invested in services for our
residents so I welcome that fall and I
think we will be taking a look at the E
mark reserves and seeing how they can be
invested for the future of our
residents
um council plan I just go very slightly
off pieced if I may Mr Perks um at this
point just to say that the we have the
2.2 million towards our Council change
our council plan and change
program that will invest in the changes
needed to safeguard against future
Financial pressures we need to invest in
new technologies in commercialization in
service improvement and stronger
Partnerships with the voluntary sector
and stream streamlining existing Council
processes and that will ensure that we
can continue to deliver high quality
coste effective services in the longer
term I'm just going to pick up the
comment made by the leader of the
opposition that
yes the additional income from interest
rates is a welcome addition to the
council's
funds
however were it not for the conservative
government's disastrous economic
policies those interest rates wouldn't
have gone as high as they have residents
wouldn't have been facing double- digit
inflation food inflation in excess of
15% so I think and were we not in such a
volatile situation with interest rates
unknown we wouldn't have to perhaps hold
as Mr B is proposing 1.5 million p in an
inflation Reserve
were the situation more stable and we
had a more stable economic Outlook some
of that e that um inflation Reserve
which I think is prudent to hold at this
point that could be released but we have
to protect our residents against the
against a very uncertain
future thank
you yeah I think just like to come back
briefly we have been looking at the the
budget and obviously with the the 2.32 7
million additional interest U figures uh
without that it' been an online
shortfall about 660,000 so this this
money has been helpful just come back
that you know the economic it's not just
affecting this country the economic
uncertainty obviously the last few years
we've had covid we've got the issues in
Ukraine which have caused sign
significant inflationary aspects
throughout the whole of Europe not just
just in Stratford and uh we've got the
volatile situation in the Middle East
again which is potentially causing the
increas in of petrol prices and making
uh people make different Arrangements
which in causing additional costs in in
terms of transport and not necessarily
actuallyy going through the seice canal
or that way in different areas so I
think to just blame the government for
all these things
um is slightly unfair and we must
remember that over the years that the
liberal Democrats were actually in
Coalition for for the first five years
of this government so just some slightly
points there and V you gone off piece I
thought I might as well go slightly off
piece on that
one I
think if we started to get political
which I I hope we're not but if you
start comparing um the UK to all the
other G7 countries I think you find that
we're in a very poor
position uh thank you very much indeed
uh and we're quite unique in that in
some of the issues that um uh that where
we we seem to have been hit hardest of
any comparable country in in um you know
not only in the G7 but in in many other
comparable economies uh so uh we we
we'll leave it at that uh and uh the re
the recommendations now councilor Curtis
do you want to come in before the
recommendation well if or leader may I
just add one other comment I meant to
make and it's it's it's picking up on
the comment about
variances um some variances in budget
are inevitable I'm sure we all know that
from our own personal budgeting I
certainly do um you know it's events
Dear Boy and events such as the
ettington recycling fire um and you know
the UN un unexpected uh levels of
interest income now we have finalized
the budget for 2014 4 25 there are other
areas that I of financial management
that I would like to explore with Mr
Burl and one of those is profiling
through the year to see if we can't see
any uh ways that we can better profile
so that we are able to avoid some more
expected variances if you like and I'd
like to also look at any see if there
are consistent overspends or UND spends
see if there is room for Improvement so
having got the budget process out of the
way for now Al though it obviously
starts again imminently there are other
areas in finances that I would like to
spend some time looking at with Mr Burl
but in the meantime leader yes I'd like
to propose those proposals thank you so
the proposals have been uh that proposed
uh I don't know if anybody wants to
Second them uh but the recommendations
are that the actual net variances at
period 10 and the estimated Revenue out
to him for 2023 24 are received any
issues identified for further
consideration to be addressed by a
further report to the cabinet the
portfolio holder and that the right offs
contained with paragraph 2.3 be noted uh
and we will get a further reports back
councelor Curtis I I've been assured of
that so thank you very much indeed um so
we've had the that that um proposed did
we have it seconded I councelor calls uh
and the U recommendations are you happy
to move them
okay thank
you and moving on uh issues from OB and
scrutiny committee is there any issues
that you want to raise councelor Trump
ju just briefly with cover most of them
um one of the big important things that
came was the council serious Finance
Duty oh sorry I'll just ignore um there
was the serious violence Duty that
straford District Council has in in
association with with as well um so so
that's really good presentation from Sam
santic and jnon toy um it's all about
engaging with people we need to
understand the issues causing the
serious violence um but counselors have
a players a part to play in this uh to
engage to engage with the communities
particularly around domestic violence
that seems to be under reported in rural
areas so again if we can find out what
is you know we've got a really important
role we've also got a part engaging with
Parish councils Local Schools volunte
organizations Community groups again to
spare spread awareness of serious
violence domestic violence and the
importance of social investment so um
really good talk um and then again we
touch on areas um through the planning
process as CCTV how we can integrate
things into to local plan and making
sure
making the sure that the far alarms work
as well um no seriously um social
infrastructure is just is just as
important as well as hard infrastructure
so that builds on the point about
Community Builder and we also spoke at
the same time the importance of um pubs
in terms of our task and finish group
and what parts I plan the community is
well it's sort about social cohesion as
well so that was about it thank you
I'm just wondering um councelor Crump
whether it's um something that maybe the
over and scrutiny committee might be
interested in because um as you know the
when it comes to the Domestic Abuse Act
responsibilities the County Council has
received two substantial sums from
government for uh in both 23 24 uh there
is a a contract that's arranged through
Refuge um for for running the domestic
abuse refuge in Stratford uh and the the
requirement for Under The Domestic Abuse
Act to deliver units of Refuge uh is
done by wara County Council uh in this
District but I would like to know just
how well they are performing on that
maybe that's something that the over on
scrutiny committee could could ask about
because uh we work in partnership with
the County Council but it is the county
council's overall responsibility but
they are delivering a service for this
area and we have to work with them uh is
that a subject that may be subject that
an over the portfolio holder who who
happens to be sitting here talking to
you now um so I'm I'm more than happy to
um yes we have got this Duty safe
accommodation I think there's an extra
36 units off the top of my head coming
not um not just in the Hall of warshire
for safer accommodation to cover
different needs and so the families can
go and there's all sorts of um different
needs that we're trying to accommodate
so yes I think we can uh I'm more than
happy to speak to the portfol holder at
the county to to get some at the yes
indeed in order that we work better
together because um you know there's so
much of that responsibility is with the
County Council we'd like to know um just
just how that applies to this district
and how we can uh work with it with it
in that in that area thank you some
great work is going on and refuge
exemplars in this area so yeah it's is
really positive so I'm sure we can get
that on the work program
ASAP we've got cabinet committees that
were on uh and uh on block items um
there unless anybody has requested made
a request uh for the item to discussed
and I've have received no requests they
are taken on block and that's the
housing investment panel and the member
development uh working group
so councelor
ccha I was in attendance at the uh
housing investment panel and I'm not
included in the uh on on the report
good
point Part F of the matters urgent
business uh I've received nothing and uh
we have already discussed the items that
would have excluded the public so we
don't need to exclude the P public um
that there were two exempt appendixes um
but we haven't needed to to discuss them
but just to bring them to your attention
that they were to exempt items uh and on
that note I think we've reached the end
of the meeting so I declare